اذا تستمر الاحتجاجات في ايران ويستمر
معها قمع النظام للشعب بشتى الوسائل
محاولات حجب الايرانيين عن العالم الخارجي
عبر قطعه الانترنت لكن مهلا فهناك حل ستار
لينك احدى ادوات رئيس شركه سبيس اكس ايلون
ماسك المؤثره الماسك اعلن ان ما يقرب من
مئه محطه محطه استقبال ارضيه لخدمات
الانترنت المؤمنه عبر شبكه ستارلينج
للاقمار الاصطناعيه تعمل في ايران حاليا
تعمل في داخل ايران الملياردير الامريكي
وعد في سبتمبر باتاحت الانترنت عبرته
للاقمار الاصطناعيه في ايران مع فرض
السلطات الايرانيه قيودا متزايده على
الوصول الايرانيين الى الانترنت
على مقطع فيديو ونشره على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مستخدم قال انه التقط في
الشوارع
قال انه التقط في شوارع ايران حيث توجد
الان حوريات اكبر للنساء في اختيار ما اذا
كنا يريدنا تغطيه شعرهن ام لا وتشهد ايران
منذ السادس عشر من سبتمبر احتجاجات عقب
مقتل الشاب الكرديه الايرانيه محسا امينه
بعد ثلاثه ايام من توقيفها من قبل شرطه
الاخلاق لعدم التزامها القواعد الصارمه
لللباس واكدت سلطات مقتله اكثر من 200 شخص
بينما تشير منظمات حقيقيه خارجه ايران الى
مقتل اكثر من 450 من المحتجين على ايدي
قوه الامن
وقد تم توقيف الالاف على هامش الاحتجاجات
التي تخللها رفع الشعارات مناهضه للسلطات
واعتبر مسؤول جزءا كبيرا منها اعمل شقبا